هناك دليل جديد على أن الهواء الذي تتنفسه المرأة الحامل يمكن أن يؤثر
على الجنين وفقًا لدراسة نُشرت
في مجلة Nature Communications ،
وجد باحثون أنه عندما
تتنفس المرأة الحامل الكربون الأسود ،
يمكن للجسيمات الضارة أن تشق طريقها
من الرئتين إلى المشيمة ويمكن أن
من المحتمل أن يصل الهواء الملوث إلى الجنين
يمكن أن يسبب مشاكل صحية بمجرد
ولادة الطفل
ينتج تلوث الكربون الأسود عن طريق
احتراق الوقود الأحفوري الذي يمكن أن
يأتي من السيارات أو محطات توليد الطاقة.فحصت الدراسة الصغيرة
المشيمة من 25
من الأمهات غير المدخنات مباشرة بعد
ذلك.  أنجب باحثون يقولون إنه كلما زاد
الكربون الأسود الذي تعرضت له النساء
أثناء الحمل ، تم العثور على المزيد من الملوثات
في المشيمة ، وحذرت الدراسة من
أن هناك حاجة إلى مزيد من البحث لإظهار
ما إذا كانت
الجسيمات الملوثة داخل المشيمة يمكن أن تصل إلى الجنين
مباشرة ، لكن الباحثين يقولون إن
تثبت النتائج أن المشيمة ليست
حاجزًا لا يمكن اختراقه في يومنا هذا
دقيقة الصحة أنا ماندي جيثر